Bob honey who just do stuff the the pro
style is is really fun and it's and it's
very lyrical and so obviously I love
that aspect of the book the central
character in the book and I think I
should just get it out there there's so
much to him and he's complex and he's
interesting and he has these adventures
one of the things he does is he's on a
mission to just say it to kill old
people to kill old people why is he
doing that I know why because I've read
the book but maybe you could explain
well there's a there's an issue of
flatulence related to the ozone mm-hmm
and there's a lack of engagement with
social media to a degree and therefore
global consumerism and so in in culling
certain demographics we make a better
world yeah that's this that's this
that's this theory not your theory that
is the theory of this of this man Bob
honey who does it in a very interesting
way and when you read it it actually
comes across some of the scenes come
across as very funny and I know it
you're just gonna have to take my word
for it then you hear it when you hear it
it sounds like how could that possibly
yes
you couldn't tell from the picture
you're very clear that yeah and you
yourself I think have felt like look you
if you get some backlash about that from
say the elderly community or anyone
who's offended what would you say to
them I you know there's a there's a
fashion today of of questioning all
humor or or in fact is this it's a sort
of self-censorship
and what I would say to anybody who's it
was offended by this because I took care
to write a book that starts on page one
and and doesn't end till it ends and if
and if read fully in in context what I
would say is I'm 57 my pools he did you
can say anything
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you